[Music]
welcome everyone to session 62 of the
world of speculative fiction series
this one is a little bit of a return to
a proverbial blast from the past we
covered rogers alaskni's chronicles of
amber in the very first year of the
worlds of speculative fiction series
that's 2016 when it was still a
face-to-face meeting group and now we're
returning to it because in that first
session we only did the first five books
which are centered on the main character
of corey or corwin and now in these next
five and final books of the chronicles
of amber we are going to be looking at
the
comings and goings of a lot of different
characters including uh corwin at a
certain point but mostly centering on
his
son
merlin who is both a child of amber and
a child of chaos and if you don't know
what that means well we're going to get
into that soon as we talk about the
metaphysics of this incredible narrative
universe so i've got all five books here
in my hand you notice that this is quite
a manageable read each of these is is uh
you know fairly short some of them are
not even 200 pages and they constitute a
deeply interwoven
rich
fantasy
world you know
connected with alternate realities
including our own here on earth which is
part of what they call
shadow
so we're going to be looking at
some some of the world building the
additional world building that goes on
within these five volumes we'll be
talking a lot about the characters and
their history and there's a ton
of philosophical themes woven into this
series many many of them ethical and
metaphysical and epistemological so it's
going to be a lot of fun to
discuss
now the world's a speculative fiction
series for anybody who doesn't know is
this ongoing generally monthly series
that i have been doing since 2016
originally partnering with and invited
by the brookfield public library to come
in and give monthly talks about
speculative fiction universes and
philosophical themes
you know everybody from from tolkien to
the queen to zelazny to
contemporary authors as well and
eventually you know when we hit a little
road bump due to covet and couldn't meet
anymore the series went on hold until we
discovered the possibilities of this
format so what we do is a roughly 90
minute video like the one you're
watching right now which we premiere and
have some live chat so there's an
interactive component there
and then we hold a online session of
video conferencing for more intimate and
engaging continuation of the discussions
we have some regulars who show up but
it's open to anybody else who wants to
participate as well i typically provide
the link to that at the end of this
session so anybody who wants to can join
in so
very happy to be going back into these i
gave them a re-read
recently uh not least because i was
bedridden with covid for
about a week and
i just happened to have gotten my hands
on all of these so i was like well
stuck in bed
may as well read and what a delight they
were i remember
there's a little bit of a background for
me these came out when i was in high
school and in college and i'd read
others zelazny works and very much
enjoyed them
including the earlier chronicles of
amber and i remember as these came out
and i was reading them i had a similar
reaction to many fans which is well
these are not these are good but not
great like the original five
and
i'm revising that now these are
just as great as the original five and
i'm really happy to have reread them
especially as an adult who can catch
more than the teenager and college
student i was because these are really
excellent and they
really do expand the narrative scope of
the series so
we're not going to do a lot of talking
about biography i will talk about
reviews of these volumes and what what
zelazny himself had to say but we don't
need to do biography because we did that
in the first session which you can
easily find in the playlist for these
talks
we will talk a lot about the additional
world building that is going on we'll
also have to do a little bit of review
of the world building that happened in
the earlier
novels and then we'll talk about a host
of
interesting philosophical themes that
are raised explored or sometimes they're
just sitting in the background in these
wonderful
five additional chronicles of amber
books
the chronicles of amber you could say
are primarily 10 books written by roger
zelazny over the course of
more than two decades a little bit more
than that amount of time really 21 years
if we're counting publication
and you know neatly breaks down into the
corwin cycle which we've already talked
about before and then the merlin cycle
now the corwin cycle
is going to set a lot of the
groundwork you could say and so we'll
have to reference it to some degree and
it makes a lot of sense because it is a
shared
universe or you might say
shared multiverse as well if we think
about the metaphysics of it although
it's a very coherently connected
multiverse for reasons we'll talk about
in a bit
and
you know if we want to think about um
the biography
and reviews and viewpoints on some of
that we already discussed in the
previous session devoted to the first
five books of the chronicles of amber
and so we don't have to cover a lot of
old ground it is good to say this by the
time that zelazny
is writing the second set of the
chronicles of amber he is a totally
established sci-fi and fantasy author
with many awards a lot of things to his
name i mean you can say a similar thing
to some degree about the earlier cycle
although he's he's more young and hungry
and up and coming
at that time
so the first ones are written in the 70s
and we it's a period essentially of
eight years uh the first one is in 1970
followed in 1972
and then it's a little bit of a hiatus
and then 1975 1976 and 1978 effectively
bringing that series to a close well
beloved
made a huge impact on its readership and
his his fan base and then he
reapproaches the series in
1985 with this
first uh new amber novel at last in
paperback is how it's written on this
the trumps of doom in 1985
and he follows it fairly quickly in 1986
1987 for the next two books so he's kind
of on a roll and then it's spaced out a
little bit more 1989 1991
so it's a shorter time frame a bit that
these are being
developed within
and you know it brings the series to a
fairly successful conclusion not every
thread
is wrapped up there was room for perhaps
more to go on and it could be that roger
zelazny's untimely death uh
put the the kibosh on that uh he might
have done prequels himself the way that
his estate
more or less against zelazny's wishes
they brought in bettencourt to write
these inferior uh novels just about
everybody acknowledges that they're
they're not as good as the amber novels
but we're going to concentrate here on
what is going on
in
his views and his mindset with these
novels we'll talk about one review very
briefly
there wasn't an awful lot of
contemporary review stuff available but
there was a review that i thought was
was quite insightful so going back to
the original series
zelazny wrote to andre norton
that the title nine princes and amber
had a dual intent
it refers to the city of amber and the
you know worlds that are associated
around it and the influences it would
have on the people there and then he
also said it it referred to
the characters embedded like insects in
amber here's the quote individuals
frozen in timeless moments of some
particular passion or phase of their
lives as though contained like one of
those insects and this is kind of an
interesting thing to say given that what
we discover
is that
some of the characters do in fact
change and transform and grow
not just uh corwin himself
but also his brother random who will
become the king
of amber right and even it's revealed
that his brother eric who he has this
horrible
feud with right
is um
not as bad as as he thought and
the other character bran turns out to be
the big baddie uh who is you know doing
some terrible things we actually find
out how that works in these later
five books so it's an interesting
characterization but does it really
hold up another thing that we find from
ted crulick in interviews with roger
zelazny roger zelazny said this if there
is an infinity of parallel worlds in
which anything can exist and if one of
them allowed for a race of intelligent
beings with the ability to traverse any
of these worlds under their own power it
follows one particular world must be the
keystone
or archetypal world i looked at it from
a sort of radial symmetry and placed
this world in the middle of the others
in concentric rings
just this mental image when it came
along for some reason the name amber
occurred to me so this is the
narrative universe that things are set
in we have at the beginning of the first
five books
amber is the center of the universe as
it's going to turn out
no it's not it is
one of the main polls and it's not the
original
center as a matter of fact it's fairly
recent in history
and it's kind of an offspring of of the
courts of chaos which we'll find out a
lot more about in this
subsequent five books but that's
important stage setting right there now
zelazny in
1985 uh in an interview with ted krulick
so we're talking about the year that
this novel comes out
zelazny says
in trumps of doom i decided to start in
the here and now
and then go off into more fantastic
adventures following the pattern of nine
princes in amber i wanted to parallel
the series in that respect i like the
way it worked out the first time so i
decided to start this one that way also
and going around our earth asking
questions of various people
merle is acting like a detective
pounding the pavement as you said to get
answers the way i'm setting up the novel
there's an element of mystery i like the
patterning of a mystery story i
sometimes try to work that in
i didn't want merle to be another
version of corwin so i made him seem
uncritical of others even a bit naive
hopefully he's going to be learning as
he goes along partly i think his seeming
innocence is justified because most of
that first book takes place on earth and
he's not originally from earth
i wanted him to feel a little bit out of
place in society and maybe a little bit
more trusting but i also didn't want to
do another series
with a character who was just like
corwin merle is a nicer guy than his
father in many ways i think i've got to
get him over being a nicer guy i'll try
to wise him up a bit as the story moves
along and indeed that happens so you
know really two
key things to draw as you know jewels
out of this
one of them is that he there's a
deliberate parallelism
between the new series as it's being
brought out and being conceived at the
beginning in zelazny's own mind and if
you think about the great arc of the
previous series so you know this whole
thing about mysteries
plays a big role
we start with
a corwin in you know the very first book
who is on earth doesn't realize that he
belongs to this you know family uh
ruling in amber
because he's lost his memory he thinks
that he's from
earth and then finds out no he isn't
especially after he
walks the pattern
and not not the original one in amber
castle itself but the other one in
rebma which is amber backwards right
and
then regains his memory and we find out
that there's sort of like plots within
plots within plots within plots
we're going to see something very
similar
taking place in um these next five
novels as well and mystery we'll come
back to in just a moment the other thing
that i think is incredibly important
is that zelazny says
i'm not just taking the same character
changing his name slightly making him
the kid the knockoff the sidekick
whatever we want to call it of the first
character
and then having him go through similar
paces
instead i've got a different guy and
this is a person who
wants to you know figure things out
about his father but also has to figure
all sorts of other things out who knows
that he is not of the earth but is
spending time there on the earth in part
to try to get to understand his own
father who's who was so you know
let's call it enthrall they're
infatuated with this wonderful shadow
world but then also
elevated it as we're going to talk about
later to perhaps a
higher status by creating a new
metaphysical grounding pattern that
incorporated all these aspects of earth
into it so corwin is a different kind of
character
this is very very important i think
in the same interview a little bit later
on zelazny says i have to introduce a
bunch of other elements now
because i left an awful lot of things
unexplained in trump's in in this first
new novel right which i want to go back
to and explain in the course of doing
that i have to go along two different
lines before i can get on with the story
so the second book
blood of amber is not a simple linear
extension
of trump's we see the development going
on here
another thing that he says
elsewhere well actually which is said
about him
rather by andrew mather in the quill to
live which i think is is kind of
interesting
one of the most more noticeable changes
in scenery between the two cycles is
world building style while the core wind
cycle the first five books has a certain
scrappy quality to it the emphasis is
much more on whimsy than on rigid
structure the locations zelazny takes us
to in part one are all to explicitly
serve the plot they tend to feel like a
video game with bad rendering
everything around the protagonist feels
real but look into the distance and
things start to get pixelated quickly
now
that kind of makes sense if the worlds
in shadow are not quite as real as amber
right
he goes on and says however in the
merlin cycle we get a much more
well-defined setting the number of
places the story jumps to
decreases slightly but in exchange they
feel like actual places that exist
outside the characters needs in theory
this more concrete grounding should have
appealed to us more but there's
definitely something lost from the
series as a whole a lot of what makes
the story interesting is it's ephemeral
nature know the places we visit in the
first cycle aren't well defined and that
can be frustrating but it serves to
paint a picture of a universe with amber
at its center by tying down the world
building with more concrete places the
second cycle feels inherent less
inherently ambery
somehow
i don't fully agree with this i would
say that
there is
in the second cycle perhaps a greater as
he's saying
definitiveness about the places there's
more that's being said their connections
with each other are a little bit more
clearly defined
i'm not sure that there's actually less
places i think the universe actually
expands
considerably in the
final five books by comparison to the
first five books so i think
you know if we counted them up which i
haven't done
maybe we would find that to be
the case
another thing that
mather says in this review that i'm
going to come back to shortly
it could be said that the major question
that permeates all the corwin cycle is
how
how does the magic work how is corwin
going to take the throne how will he
find the willpower to survive
this latest trial but the question that
suffuses the merlin cycle is
why
why are these things happening why is
someone trying to kill merlin why is his
father disappeared the shift goes from
exploration to mystery and it changes
the very nature of the story now we
should think about this a bit is this
really the case or is mather being a
little bit too
rigid in his dichotomy here there is an
awful lot of how
being developed within the
mer the merlin cycle the final five
books how does the you know
keep of the five worlds
four worlds rather actually work um
how is
this character doing these things how
are these uh
schemes going to play out how are the
pattern and the logos and the new
pattern and ghost wheel and the
spikenard how are these connected to
each other and we are getting answers to
a lot of these things
i think there's something important here
though too the why so we've got the how
the mechanics and then we've got the why
you could call it the philosophy the
background the
you know motivations and stuff like that
and in the first five books those are
being revealed as well you know why
is uh the black road making its way into
amber well because uh you know there was
an opening that was created
by brand collaborating
with uh chaos right to and why is chaos
uh striving against amber is it just
that that's the case or something like
that where is this
uh
enmity coming from now there's i would
say
more of the why
in the
uh final five books that's perhaps
quite true
and he goes on and he says the fact that
the merlin cycle is couched in mystery
serves to further distance it from its
more whimsical
predecessor in order to solve puzzles
and crimes you need to have hard facts
you can rely on tangible pieces of a
puzzle that don't shift when you look
away from them as a result zelazny
starts to lay the groundwork for a much
more rigid and clearly defined world so
narrative universe not just single world
um
which as we mentioned is a bit weird to
put at the end of your ten book series
and yet the mystery sections work
surprisingly well
understanding how amber works is really
fun and it's a great stepping stone into
some fairly captivating whodunits the
mystery also serves well to tie the two
cycles more cleanly together
and to make them feel much more
synchronized it was surprising it was
surprising but excellent idea that
differentiates the merlin cycle while
also bridging the two cycles at the same
time
i like that i think that's that's on
point the there is you know these are
two different cycles but they are
connected together and you can say that
the second cycle telescopes out and then
adds a lot of additional
matters
expanding the the numbers of characters
and family members uh you know talking
more about the worlds in shadow at least
those around amber telling us a lot more
about the courts of chaos and how things
work there telling us a bit more about
earth as as a shadow world so there is
something there and and
i think that
these are indeed um
mysteries
mystery
is is a an important part of this
mystery in the the genre sense right
and also fantasy is playing a major role
we can say that there's other genres
kind of blended in here as well and you
know it's interesting one of the reviews
that was done that i quite like from a
while back by william cardini
um
he ends up saying
that
um
there is a sort of cyberpunk
aspect
to the the new ones in part because of
uh ghost wheel right so we'll we'll yeah
here we go um
the cor well corwin is a charismatic
rogue merlin is a fair-minded nerd
um
corwin is modern noir
merlin is contemporary cyberpunk for as
an example at the beginning of the first
book trump's of doom merlin has just
quit a computer startup in the bay area
and is going off to check on the
artificial intelligence he built in the
hinterlands of shadow now whether it is
really cyberpunk or just has cyberpunk
elements i think that's a very important
uh question
and i i think the answer is is it's not
really cyberpunk any more than it's
really a mystery but it weaves these
together
with um traditional fantasy and you
could also say is very important you
know all the power struggles that are
going on
especially in the families
zelazny took that he says quite you know
clearly
from uh philip jose farmer's world of
tears which by the way we've we devoted
two different sessions to in the series
you can find them uh easily and
you know this this development of
plots and revelations and
alignments coalitions reworkings of that
plays a really central
role in this
let's come back to the mystery aspect
for just a moment and then we'll come
back to this this other review that i
think is is quite good so in uh trumps
of doom and in blood of amber and i'm
only picking out these two because there
are other mysteries that are being
brought up and then you know mostly
resolved in these other three books but
just in the first
book and and also in the second book we
have a number of different
mysteries some of them interconnected as
part of the mystery as well how are
these different mysteries connected with
each other
being brought up so the the very first
one is who's trying to kill me
it begins by
it is a pain in the ass waiting around
for someone to try to kill you but it
was april 30th and of course it would
happen as it always did it had taken me
a while to catch on but now i at least
knew when it was coming in the past i'd
been too busy to do anything about it
but my job was finished now i'd only
stayed around for this i felt that i
really ought to clear the matter up
before i departed before i leave earth
to go work on my ghost wheel
elsewhere and what is the mystery
someone keeps trying to kill me on
april 30th while pergus knocked it gets
brought up as well and then uh there's a
second mystery that comes in he meets
with his friend luke who is going to be
a very interesting character as well
and
luke gives him a thing from julia julia
wants to meet him he goes to julia's
place and finds what he thinks to be
julia's corpse and a
terrible hell beast that is he has to
fight
uh and and deal with right and then the
question is
what's going on with this uh he says i
returned to julia's side and held her
hand i began to realize my anger someone
had to be behind this could it be s his
mysterious uh assassin again was this my
april 30 present for the year i had a
feeling that it was and i wanted to do
on to us as i'd just done unto the
creature that had performed the act
there had to be a reason there ought to
be a clue right and then he goes on to
the next uh part of the mystery which is
um talking to a guy who
knew julia who dated him
and he tells a story which i'm not going
to
rehearse
and then this is very interesting
because this is sort of a denial of
mystery
so
this other uh
guy who owns a bookstore who dated julia
briefly
says i've heard it said by a number of
people some of them fairly reliable
that mel-min really has something going
for him that he has a hold on a piece of
something that he's known a kind of
enlightenment has been initiated has a
sort of powered and sometimes a great
teacher but he's got these ego problems
too that seem to go along with that sort
of thing and there's a touch of the simi
side there i've even heard it said it's
not his real name that he's got a record
and there's more of manson to him than
magus i don't know he's nominally a
painter actually a pretty good one his
stuff does sell well
and
he says i wanted to study with him he
turned me down
and then
merlin says so you were into this too i
thought and he says i'm not into
anything i tried everything at one time
or another
i mean everybody goes through phases i
wanted to develop expand advance who
doesn't but i never found it
he unbent and took another gulp of wine
sometimes i felt that i was close that
there was some power some vision i could
almost touch or see almost then it was
gone it's all a lot of crap you just
delude yourself sometimes i even thought
i had it then a few days would go by and
i realized i was lying to myself again
and he says that's what held us together
for a while then she got too serious
about it and i didn't feel like going
that route again and then he says
there's nothing to any of it there are
an infinite ways number of ways of lying
to yourself of rationalizing things into
something they're not i guess that i
wanted magic
and there is no real
magic in the world now this guy
really
he's on the right track for a bit and
then he pulls back and becomes cynical
there's no magic there's no mystery and
in these stories of course there is and
there might be even in too much of it
um
he
corwin
merlin um you know goes to see melman
and he says something else that's very
interesting here
grief and anger
shrink my world and i resent this they
seem to paralyze my memory of happier
times of friends places things options
squeezed by the grip of intense
unsettling emotion i grow smaller in my
single-mindedness i suppose it is partly
because i've discarded a range of
choices impairing in some measure my
freedom of will i don't like this
but after a point i have
some small control over it it makes me
feel i have surrendered to a kind of
determinism which irritates me even more
then vicious cycle this feeds back into
the emotion that drives me and
intensifies it the simple way of ending
this situation is the headlong rush to
remove its object the difficult way is
more philosophical a drawing back
a re-establishment of control as usual
the difficult way is preferable a
headlong rush may result in a broken
neck now a little bit of digression here
when people are claiming that you know
merlin is much more cerebral
you know
he's not a swashbuckling adventurer like
his dad corwin
well yes
that's right but it's not because he
simply has a different temperament it's
because he is
choosing to be that way and it's taking
an effort right and this is quite
important now he shows up at melman's
place and now the question is well who's
this guy and who is
behind him now we're getting
more and more involved in the mystery
another one that i do want to bring up
that uh thickens the plot so to speak
in trump's of doom and this is about uh
two thirds of the way through he you
know uh merlin goes back to amber
and as it turns out there's been an
assassination
kane his uncle
his father's brother
is dead
and
this is random telling him that
cain is dead murdered this morning he
was off in shadowdega a distant port
with which we have commerce he was with
gerard to renegotiate an old trade
agreement he was shot through the heart
died instantly
did they catch the bowman
bowman hell it was a rifleman on a
rooftop and he got away
i thought gunpowder didn't work around
here gunpowder doesn't work by the way
in amber that's why corwin who discovers
that jeweler's rouge will actually
detonate like
like powder will has a a bunch of
mercenaries armed with
special made bullets to bring them in
somebody else has discovered this
and
random says i don't know dega may be far
enough in shadow for gunpowder to work
nobody can remember ever testing any
there
for that matter your father once came
out with a compound that worked there
anyway the funeral is tomorrow so the
question is
who killed the prince of amber and how
the hell did that happen so now we've
got two different mysteries or sets of
mysteries colliding one on a smaller
scale who's trying to kill me who killed
julia who's behind this victor mellman
guy
all for corwin and then the much larger
picture who the hell is killing amber
rights
and
for what reason what's what's going on
when we get into the second
um
blood of amber we we get some other
things being introduced as well
luke uh is uh
um
in
vinta
you know who was the
widow now at this point he's is in her
place but vinta
is not vinta
vinta bale
and um
who is
inhabiting her consciousness well we you
know in the earlier parts of the book we
had other
people who play a role in uh
merlin's life and actually in luke's
life too
who
are moving from body to body to body
there's a consciousness and so there's a
question well who is this turns out it's
going to be a demon
and
why is it doing this well to protect
merlin also protecting luke until uh
figures out that luke is not uh the
object of protection but there's that
question that has to be resolved and you
know that's that's another interesting
one who sent this who tamed this demon
who compelled it to do that and then we
get another really interesting mystery
being raised as well
in um
blood of amber
so this
involves um the pattern right
so
there's kind of a reminiscence that's
that's going on here with fiona
taking young merlin to the pattern that
her father that that his father her
brother
had created
and um she he says the view in the
mirror was not the same as that which
had presented itself to my unaided
scrutiny i was able to see beyond the
tree now through the fog to discern most
of the strange pattern which twisted its
bright way around the ground working its
passages inward to its off-center
terminus the only spot still concealed
by an unmoving tower of white within
which tiny lights like stars seem to
burn
it doesn't look like the pattern back in
amber i said no she answered is it
anything like the logos
not really the logarist actually alters
itself somewhat constantly still it's
more angular whereas this is mostly
curves and bends so he studies the
pattern for a while and she says none of
us can actually walk this pattern we'll
talk about that in a moment
and he you know she says you should try
it and he pretends that it doesn't work
and then
she says um
i was hoping that someone other than
corwin might be able to walk it
his son seemed the most likely choice
merlin then says why is it so important
someone walk it just because it's there
fiona says i think it's a menace it has
to be explored and dealt with a menace
why now here's where we get metaphysical
and this is another part of the mystery
amber and chaos are the two poles of
existence as we understand it housing as
they do the pattern and the logos for
ages there has been something of an
equilibrium between them now i believe
this bastard pattern of your fathers is
undermining their balance
in what fashion there have always been
wave-like exchanges between amber and
chaos
this seems to be setting up some
interference
it sounds more like tossing an extra ice
cube into a drink i said it should
settle down after a while
she shook her head things are not
settling there have been far more shadow
storms since this thing was created they
rend the fabric of shadow they affect
the nature of reality
not good i said another event a lot more
important along these lines occurred at
the same time
the original pattern in amber was
damaged and oberyn repaired it the wave
of chaos which came out of that swept
through olive shadow everything was
affected but the pattern held and things
settled again i'd be more inclined to
think of all those extra shadow storms
as being in the nature of aftershocks
it's a good argument she said
but what if it's wrong
so
this is
interesting now we have we could say
like
several different
interlocking
mysteries that have to be worked through
and resolved we got cor yeah merlin with
his own you know questions who's trying
to kill me what happened to julia what's
going on with this eventually there's
gonna be questions well who is luke
actually since luke imprisons him at the
end of the second book or the end of the
first book and he he's able to get out
in in the second book and then engage
with with luke
all of these personal mysteries and then
the larger
mystery what's going on with people
killing princes of amber who is our true
enemy
how do we negotiate
these matters and then we've got a
cosmic truly truly cosmic set of
mysteries
what's happening here
with the pattern and the logarithms and
this
extra bastard pattern
that corwin made himself how are all of
these things connected with each other
and these these are important mysteries
so we're going to go into those in just
a bit i do want to come back to this
other review very briefly
by william cardini
he says something very interesting here
from the reviews i saw on amazon and
goodreads i expected to not like the
merlin cycle as much as the corwin cycle
maybe it was because of these lowered
expectations but i enjoyed merlin maybe
more so than corwin
and
i had a similar sort of thing i
mentioned already that i read these when
i was in high school and college and and
didn't find them i enjoyed them but i
didn't find them as good as the original
corwin cycle things but i think that's
in part because
i
myself hadn't matured enough to
appreciate
certain aspects of what was going on in
these other
novels these these five
novels of the the cycle that are
centered on merlin and i think there's a
general consensus it seems to be among a
lot of people that these just aren't as
good
as the originals and i think that's
actually quite wrong
so you know he's here's where he said
corwin is a charismatic rogue merlin is
a fair-minded nerd but we've already
seen that merlin is not just a
fair-minded nerd there's a lot of his
father in him
uh this you know sort of
single-mindedness the anger the the then
he has to try to overcome it
and he says in many ways the merlin
cycle parallels the corwin cycle
structurally again what zelazny himself
had said right we begin on earth but are
swiftly inducted into amberite intrigue
we go through several rounds of
mysterious betrayals and reversals until
the true powers behind events are
revealed quite true the plotting centers
on family dynamics and once again a
missing father although
zelazny adds layers of motivations
meanings and metaphysics to his cosmos
the stakes feel lower this second go
around both cycles end abruptly but
prince of chaos leaves many more threads
undone than the courts of chaos that i
disagree with
meaning the
the stakes feel lower i don't think
that's actually the case i think the
stakes in some respects
are actually more clearly defined and in
some respects higher there is a struggle
going on within existence itself
between
chaos and order the pat the the logos
and
uh the pattern with other things being
thrown into the mix
now here's here's one point that i do
like about this review
one way in which the merlin cycle vastly
improves on the corwin cycle is in the
portrayal of and roles given to women
the one-dimensional lovers sisters and
mostly absent mother are replaced with a
crowd of vibrant multifaceted women i
don't recall a moment that passes the
bechdel test but merlin's complicated
and more importantly changing
relationships with his mother the mother
of his best friend his ex-girlfriend
julia and the female demon following him
give these novels so much of their depth
and drive much of the plot and i would
actually
say that
those four are indeed quite important
but the
his aunts
also play a greater role as does um the
queen of amber viale
and um
there's something interesting that that
zelazny himself
said in an interview with ted krulick
talking about um
secondary characters who support merlin
frockier
fracker is this strangling chord is a
magical entity that semi-sentient it
appears as a cord around merle's wrist
merle refers to it as female
i described fracker's background in the
special edition of trumps of doom that
underwood and miller did they asked me
to give something extra for the special
edition to give the reader something he
wouldn't get in the regular one i wrote
just a couple pages of introductory
material which flashes back it starts
out having merle negotiate the
logarithms in the back in the courts of
chaos it's explained that it is
customary when one is going through the
logarithms to take some item with him
that particular item a sword becomes a
magical sword when the person emerges
merle had gone through the logarithms
with an old piece of cord the cord
frocker is not particularly smart and
it's not 100 effective it's sensitive to
anyone's intent to cause moral harm
however the magical cord could not
anticipate a sudden attack or an
accident right but it is a female
character
merle talks to it merle relies upon it
it saves his life a number of times so i
think that's you know the ants uh the
cord
and um the two mothers
julia
and the the female demon that is trying
to protect him these are all pretty well
developed characters they get to speak
for themselves he goes on and he says
this is uh william cardini again the
imagery in the merlin cycle matches and
sometimes exceeds the psychedelia of the
corwin cycle not content to simply
rehash hell rides through shadow and the
silvery gleam of tiernan nagath zelazny
shows us the stark stage beneath the
puppetry of shadow and takes us to the
pit of chaos in between we visit the
inhospitable cave where ghost wheel
computes on his otherworldly circuitry
and the mad hatter's bar so this is all
right as well and this goes back to that
um you know thing that was
mentioned before about the the world
building
you know mather had said we get a much
more well-defined setting yes indeed and
and it's also done
in ways that are quite striking
the last thing that he says that i think
is
quite interesting
in some ways the strength of an author's
creation can be measured in how
reluctant the readers are to leave
i'd like to experience more of amber and
chaos although i don't envy those caught
in their power struggles
and that is an interesting point to make
now isn't it
we have
the first
five books the first chronicles of amber
we have these books we have some short
stories we have some inferior and pretty
much to be disavowed prequels
and the great book of amber as well
and
that's all we're going to get you know
if you think about the amount of writing
that there that we have here these are
fairly short
novels the world of tears i think which
is six novels uh is probably about the
same length of this
obviously there's there's other newer
fantasy stories that are much larger in
terms of sheer writing and perhaps
in some respects richer right we could
think of r scott backers second
apocalypse uh we could think of george r
martin's game of thrones we could think
of you know to go back to other people
andrew norton's witch world which had or
you know anne mccaffrey's world of pern
which are vast amounts of
writing
i think that zelazny
really did manage to create something
uh like he says this is again william
cardini
a place that we're reluctant to leave
and
i've very much enjoyed you know going
back into these and re-reading them
these
novels twice in the last several months
because of
the setting and the metaphysical scope
and the
characters
that are involved with it and we get to
unravel
some of their mysteries so we've ranged
quite a bit over a number of different
matters in a rather you know slipshod
manner perhaps
now it's time to concentrate a bit on
some philosophical themes that play an
absolutely central role
in these novels in the narrative
universe of
amber and shadow and chaos
one of the greatest and grandest and you
could say most grounding
philosophical themes in the chronicles
of amber the entire 10
book series
has to do with metaphysics and we could
say that it also has
moral implications as well and what do
we mean by metaphysics we're not just
thinking about it in a rather reduced
form like well what has reality and you
know what are objects or things like
that we're thinking in a very
traditionally grand scale
what's most real what caused everything
else what is driving things behind
the scenes what is the fundamental
grounding reality whatever you want to
call it and it turns out to be
plural
at the very beginning of the amber
series we're introduced to the pattern
right because corwin
walks a
mirror of the pattern and it restores to
him as memories later on he will walk
the pattern uh down in we could
facetiously call it the basement but
it's in the cavern beneath amber castle
and and the city
and we're also going to find out that
there's even a deeper pattern the primal
pattern that this pattern is in a
certain way
a
copy of and the way that it's
represented in the early books is so
there's amber which is most real
grounded around the pattern itself which
gives the
princes and princesses and king
and queen of amber whoever they happen
to be
their capacity to
walk through shadow and then there are
all these
shadow
worlds or whatever you want to call them
spread out further and further
drifting off into basically
nothingness now this turns out to be
a only partial
viewpoint on things because if you go
out far enough
you encounter
chaos
so we have the pattern
associated with the unicorn with the
house of you know
oberon and his many many children and
then we have at the other end as it
turns out not just chaos
but the courts of chaos there are people
living out there and as we find out
later
amber is a newcomer
you know oberon's father dworkin was
originally from the courts of chaos and
decided to stake out his own
place using this thing called the jewel
of judgment which allowed him to create
the pattern
in the first place so now at the the you
know the story we've got uh the pattern
we've got chaos and one of uh corwin's
brothers bran
collaborates with the forces of chaos to
try to destroy the pattern which will
allow chaos to reign because brand
actually wants to produce his own
pattern and sort of you know he's a
megalomaniac he wants to rule the
universe and brand is ultimately killed
and um
you know there's a lot of
warfare that's going on we don't have to
talk about that you can look at the
previous session about roger zlasny and
amber for that
but
corwin
creates
a new pattern using
the jewel of judgment
meanwhile his father oberon is trying to
fix
the original
pattern right
and as it turns out he succeeded in
doing that so now we have
two different patterns
and
nobody's quite sure how this is going to
turn out now i am going to read some
stuff that's not from these
five volumes and is instead from the the
fourth or the fifth of the
volumes in the first five the courts of
chaos
just a few selections that tell us about
what's going on
so um this is when there's you know a
big storm and corwin is talking
to this raven
hoogie
and
[Music]
he says
if dad failed i've got to attempt to
something that bran tried to convince me
only he could do i have to create a new
pattern and i have to do it right here
you create a new pattern if oberyn
failed how could a man who could barely
stay on his feet do it no corwin
resignation is the greatest virtue you
might cultivate i raised my head and
lowered the staff to the ground hoogie
fluttered down to stand beside it and i
regarded him
you don't want to believe any of the
things that i said do you it doesn't
matter though the conflict between our
views is irreducible i see desire as
hidden identity and striving as growth
you do not if for you the greatest good
is union with the absolute why don't you
just fly to join it now in the form of
the all-pervading chaos which approaches
if i fail here it will become absolute
as for me i must try for so long as
there is breath within me to raise up a
pattern against it i do this because i
am what i am and i am the man who could
have been king in amber and so he begins
you know inscribing the new pattern he
succeeds in doing so it takes a lot out
of him and then uh we find that oberon
is you know going to go off beyond order
beyond
chaos right
to some other
place here we go julian says dad
blaise says he wanted to be taken beyond
the courts of chaos and into the final
darkness when his time came at last so
dworkin once told me beyond chaos and
amber to a place where none reigned and
so it is fiona said but is there order
somewhere beyond that wall they come
through or does the storm go on forever
if he succeeded it is but a passing
matter and we are in no danger but if he
did not
it does not matter i said whether or not
he succeeded because i did
what do you mean she asked i believe
that he failed that he was destroyed
before he could repair the old pattern
when i saw this storm coming actually i
experienced a part of it i realized i
could not possibly make it here in time
with the jewel which he had sent to me
after his efforts brand had been trying
to get it from me all along the way to
create a new pattern he said
later that gave me the idea when i saw
that all else was failing i used the
jewel to create a new
pattern it was the most difficult thing
i ever did
but i succeeded things should hold
together after this wave passes whether
we survive it or not bran stole the
jewel from me just as i completed it
when i recovered from his attack i was
able to use the new pattern to project
me here so there is still a pattern no
matter what else happens
but corwin she said what if dan
succeeded
i do not know
it is my understanding blaise said from
things that dwarken told me that two
distinct patterns could not exist in the
same universe those in rebma and tyra
ngoth do not count being but reflections
of our own what would happen i said i
think there would be a splitting off the
founding of a new existence somewhere
what then what would be the effect be on
our own
either total catastrophe or no effect
whatsoever fiona said i can make a case
for it's going either way
then we're right back where we started i
said either things are going to fall
apart shortly or they're going to hold
so it would seem blai said it doesn't
matter if we're not going to be around
after that wave gets to us i said and it
will
and
this is you know there's a bit more
going on there including the uh you know
the the designation of random the young
scrappy screw-up brother as the new king
designated as such by the unicorn itself
giving him the jewel of judgment but the
key thing here
is that now we have in addition to chaos
two patterns
and the pattern that corwin develops as
we know from that story is one that he
pours a good bit of himself and his
memories and his loves into
and these are memories and loves of a
particular shadow
world
earth
so now
maybe earth has a sort of privileged
status we don't really
know what else do we add to the picture
of this metaphysics of now two poles and
then keeping back chaos
chaos itself is a polarity
and has something analogous to the
pattern
but older
the logos
it's similar to the pattern it is walked
by those who have the you know royal
blood
and if it doesn't uh destroy you or
drive you insane and it does drive you
insane temporarily
you come out of it with the capacity to
walk through
shadows all of these myriad
more than ten thousand perhaps infinite
other alternate worlds that are in a
certain way less real
than those uh
you know that are
amber and its immediate surroundings and
chaos the courts of chaos and immediate
surroundings by the way the courts of
chaos there's that and that's
metaphysically
completely true and existent although
it's it's constantly changing
and then there's the dark zone the
shadows that are closer
to
the courts of chaos with amber there is
the golden circle of kingdoms that are
nearby and then you can go further and
further out
into other uh existences other worlds
including that of earth
what else do we need to add to
this picture
so there's
artifacts
that are
inscribed you could say with parts
of the pattern or parts of the
logos
and so these would include the trumps
that play such an important role from
the very beginning all the way through
the trumps are essentially
well they don't have to be cards they
can be drawn on other things like uh
corwin's prison cell in the earlier uh
ones but they're generally sort of like
tarot cards they depict a person or a
place
and you can move through time and space
to get to them they can be forms of
communication they can also be vectors
of attack and they all have portions of
this magic
woven into them
another key thing that we we find as
well
is
there are artifacts like
for example corwin's sword grey wanzir
has part of the pattern inscribed in it
and then there's the jewel of judgment
now the jewel of judgment as we find out
in the first five books
is
something that contains the pattern and
we might say oh well it's you know
there's like a holograph of the pattern
inside the jewel
yes but the jewel it turns out is what
dwarken used to produce the pattern in
the first place and it's what corwin
uses to produce his pattern as well
so the jewel is in a certain sense
metaphysically prior to the pattern and
the pattern is created by the jewel
rather than the other
way around as we're going to find out in
these
other books
the
jewel
is actually the eye of the serpent of
chaos it's left eye and it was stolen
by the unicorn which is the
representation of amber of the pattern
of
order
and used by by dworkin then to create
this this entire thing so there's a lot
of
causality that gets revealed as time
goes on in this
what else do we need to
mention
there are what we call
pattern ghosts
so again something that we only find in
the
later five books
the pattern
and the logarithms and the new pattern
are all able to take the people who have
walked them prior to that
and
up to that time they can create a ghost
who has the memories of that person at
the last time that they walked it so the
logarist can do this with people who
have walked the low grass before
chaos residents
the pattern in amber can do this with
people who've walked it before many
other people including oberon himself
and then corwin's pattern can do it with
corwood
so this is quite interesting and zelazny
said something in a interview given in
1992
at stony brook university
he said i never said corwin was dead
they weren't sure what happened to
corwin the others you named anybody who
walked the pattern or who crossed
through the logaris representation was
recorded by that place so even if
they're dead their image up to the point
where they made the journey through the
pattern or through the logarist
representation they've been recorded by
the pattern or logarithms and they can
be reconstructed from that recording of
course they're blank on anything that
happened after that time
so if the last time they walked the
pattern was 20 years ago
then it would be and brand was called
back say it would be the brand of 20
years ago it was the last time he did it
or if it was ever recorded the pattern
could reconstruct it from the point when
one desired it if one was wanted it
really ignorant one could go back and
find the person when he first walked it
and used that brand who might have been
a much nicer guy
in the course of reproducing such a
person it can play with a person's mind
to the extent of laying certain
compulsions on him like deliver this
message here or go there to do that and
the person will be doing that like
someone acting under a post-hypnotic
suggestion do this but not sure why and
not caring either
these are images of course zelazny goes
on they're temporary constructs the only
way they seem to take on greater
permanence in the case of pattern ghosts
is if they drink some blood of amber
which will strengthen them so in a sense
they could be given greater permanence
at least in that way so now we have
something really interesting happening
but there's something even more
important that we're finding out
particularly
in these works something that's not
there at all
in the earlier series
the pattern
and the logos
and the new pattern
are all sentient
not only do they
have a sort of metaphysical priority so
that these beings these people you know
who could be real people they could be
ghosts
they come from all of this originally
these these metaphysical
principles
underlying everything are themselves
sentient they have intentions they have
plans they have desires
they communicate
and so what we're going to do now is
just go through some of the you know
points in the works where some of these
really
key ideas are coming up and being
discussed i should mention that there
are other
things going on there's the ghost wheel
which we'll talk about
shortly which is an artifact created by
merlin which takes on its own sentience
takes on its own life its own powers
but there's also
other things
like the spikenard which reaches out
into shadow itself and draws upon
energies there and i wanted to begin
with a
discussion that's happening in night of
shadows
that i think is quite important
so
this is um
merlin talking with
his strangling cord frockier
who now is able to speak to him at this
point
and
he says i give up walking through the
space that it occupied but minutes
before the answers are more confusing
than the situations that cause the
questions
then frocker says this to him
since we're passing between shadows
could this not be a statement that all
things are real somewhere
i suppose merlin says but i already knew
that
and that this is frocker continuing
and that all things are real in
different ways at different times in
different places
and so he responds okay what you're
saying could well be the message i doubt
that something is going to these
extremes however just to make the
philosophical points that may be new to
you but are rather well worn elsewhere
there must be a
special reason one that i still don't
grasp
and so this is this is a very
interesting set of points that are being
discussed here frocker of course is kind
of new to the game you could say
and um all of this is is uh playing a
very
interesting
role in these uh discussions that are
that are going on here so let's let's
start with
a few of the things that are happening
and we don't get a lot of this
metaphysics until the the second book i
mean the old metaphysics is being
discussed but now
there's more things going on we've
already mentioned this passage where
fiona is wanting
merlin
to
try to walk the the new pattern and she
says amber and chaos are the two poles
of existence as we understand it housing
as they do the pattern and the
logarithms for ages there's been an
equilibrium between them this bastard
pattern is undermining their
balance right
and they talk about
power
and what's going on and
so
she says merle there's some kind of
power here an immense amount of power
and then she says it's always been our
way to keep an eye on power to try to
understand it to control it because one
day it might become a threat did corwin
tell you anything anything at all as to
exactly what this represents and how we
might get a handle on it no i said
nothing beyond the fact that he made it
in a hurry to replace the old one which
he figured oberyn might not have
succeeded in repairing and then they
talk a bit about you know can we find
him or not
[Music]
and you know this is this is uh
quite interesting if we go on a bit
further into a sign of chaos
we get another important discussion and
as time goes on we start to see
that things are
the mysteries that we've been looking at
are starting to be
revealed
so this is happening in chapter three
and
it begins with an interesting
epistemological question if you had a
choice between the ability to detect
falsehood and the ability to discover
truth which one would you take there was
a time when i thought there were
different ways of saying the same thing
but i no longer believe that most of my
relatives for example are almost as good
as seeing through subterfuge as they are
at perpetuating it i'm not sure though
that they care much about truth on the
other hand i've always felt there was
something noble special and honorable
about seeking truth a thing i attempted
with ghost wheel
mandarin made me wonder though had this
made me a sucker for truth's opposite of
course it's not as cut and dried as all
that i know it's not a pure either-or
situation with the middle excluded but
rather a statement of attitude
still i was suddenly willing to concede
i might have gone to an extreme to the
point of foolhardiness and that i had
let certain of my critical faculties
doze for far too long so i wondered
about fiona's request
what makes it such a threat i asked her
it is a shadow storm in the form of a
tornado she said well there have been
such things before i answered true she
responded but they tend to move through
shadow
this one does have extension through an
area of shadow but it's totally
stationary it first appeared several
days ago and it has not altered in any
way since then
what's that come to an amber time i
asked half a day perhaps why i shrugged
i don't know just curious i don't see
why it's such a threat
here's where we get to the key point i
told you such storms had proliferated
since corwin drew the extra pattern
now they're changing in character as
well as frequency that pattern has to be
understood
soon a moment of quick reflection
showed me that whoever gained control of
dad's pattern could become master of
some terrible forces or mistress
so
supposing i walk it i said then what as
i understand from dad's story i just
wind up in the middle the same with the
pattern back home what's to be learned
from that
i studied her face for some display of
emotion but my relatives tend to have
too much control for such simple
self-betrayal as i understand it she
said brand was able to trump in when
corwin is at the middle that's the way i
understand it too so when you reach the
center i can come in on a trump i
suppose so then there will be two of us
standing at the middle of the pattern
and from there we will be in a position
to go someplace we could not reach from
any other point in existence that being
the primal pattern which lies beyond it
you're sure there is one
there must be it is in the nature of
such a construct to be scribed at a more
basic level of reality as well as the
mundane
and our purpose in traveling to that
place
that is where its secrets dwell where
its deepest magics might be learned
i see i told her then what
why there we might learn how to undo the
trouble the thing is causing that's all
her eyes narrowed
we will learn whatever we can of course
power is power and represents a threat
until it's understood
i nodded slowly but right now there are
a number of powers that are more
pressing in the threat department that
pattern is going to have to wait its
turn
even if it may represent the forces you
need to deal with your other problems
and and you know they go on and he says
i didn't say that i had no intention of
taking her to the primal pattern then
leaving her out there on her own after
all she'd tried her hand at king making
once and if bran had made it to the
throne of amber these days she would
have been standing right behind him no
matter what she had to say about it now
i think she was about to ask me to
deliver to the primal pattern then
but realized i'd already considered and
rejected it not wanting to lose face by
asking and being refused she returned to
her original
argument
and so you know
there's there's some interesting things
going on there
understanding these metaphysical
principles offers the possibility of
great power
for those who
can grasp it right and and can
manipulate it and can
use it human beings or at least you know
the amberites if they are indeed human
and they seem pretty human although in
some respects superhuman
have the possibility of messing around
with the
primal forces
of reality
in a night of shadows where we start to
see a lot of this heating up
we find out that there's not only the
pattern
and its replications and a primal
pattern of the jewel of judgment
there are also broken patterns
so
this is being
discussed
in terms of julia
and joshua and
she tells
merlin that i led julia myself through a
version of my own the way of the broken
pattern
and he says sounds like something
dangerous from the amber end of shadow i
can't fault your geography she said but
it's not all that dangerous if you know
what you're doing
it is my understanding i said that those
shadow worlds which contain shadows of
the pattern can only hold imperfect
versions and this always represents a
hazard
it's only a hazard if one does not know
how to deal with it
and you had julia walk this broken
pattern
my knowledge of what you refer to as
work walking the pattern is restricted
to what my late husband brand and
ronaldo luke have told me of it i
believe that if you follow the lines
from a definite external beginning to an
interior point where the power comes to
you yes i acknowledge in the way of the
broken pattern you enter through the
imperfection and you make your way to
the center
how can you follow the lines if they're
broken or imperfect the real pattern
would destroy you if you departed the
design
you don't follow the lines she said you
follow the interstices
and when you emerge wherever you bear
the image of the broken pattern
within you and how do you conjure with
this through the imperfection you
summoned some in the image and it is
like a dark well from which you draw
power and how do you travel among the
shadows much as i as you do as i
understand it but the break is always
with you the break i don't understand
the flaw on the pattern it follows you
through shadow it is always there beside
you as you travel sometimes as a hair
fine crack sometimes as a great chasm it
shifts about it may appear suddenly
anywhere elapse in reality this is the
hazard for those of the broken way to
fall into it is the final
death
so there's you know some quite
interesting speculation there as it
turns out the patterns some of them are
worse some of them are better right they
degenerate from shadow to shadow
and it's always dangerous to to work
with them
then uh
much later on in night of shadows
um
we find uh um
while uh merlin is at the chamber of the
pattern um
he's going to actually talk with it
right
and he says i feel really used
you've run my ass ragged you placed my
life in jeopardy more than once you got
me to perform to satisfy your
metaphysical voyeurism then you kicked
me out after you got the last thing you
wanted a slightly brighter glow i guess
the gods or powers or whatever the hell
you are don't have to say thank you or
i'm sorry or go to hell when they
finished using someone and obviously you
feel no need to justify yourself to me
well i'm not a baby carriage i resent
being pushed around by you and the
logarist in whatever game you're playing
how'd you like it if i opened a vein and
bled all over you now down doing that
will create a
damage to the pattern and perhaps even
destroy it as well
immediately there is a great coalescence
of energies at my side of the pattern
with a heavy whooshing and a tower of
blue flame built itself before me
widened assumed genderless features of
an enormous inhuman beauty i had to
shade my eyes against it
you do not understand came a voice
modulated of the roaring of flames i
know that's why i'm here
your efforts are not unappreciated glad
to hear it there was no other way to
conduct matters well were they conducted
to your satisfaction they were then
you're welcome i guess
you are insolent merlin
the way i feel right now i've got
nothing to lose i'm just too damn tired
to care what you do to me so i came down
here to tell that i think you owe me a
big one i turned my back on it then not
even oberyn dared address me so it said
i shrugged and took a step towards the
door when i set my foot down i was back
in my
apartment and
he's talking with a ghost wheel
and he says you know are you still okay
dad you know and um
merlin asked ghostwill do you know what
the pattern is up to and he says it
seems to be dueling with the logos for
control of shadow and it just went
around whatever happens seems to have
strengthened it you were involved right
and so that is that is what is being
revealed is what's going on
there's a eternal struggle between the
two of them that's going that's
occurring
and now this is the newest
form of it
now we get a really interesting thing
happening
a little bit later
an image of the pattern itself as large
as the logarithm sign had just put in an
appearance only a few feet behind me
manifesting about as far in that
direction from nadya who's occupied by
the the tiger the the demon right as the
logarist was before parenthesizing the
lady or the tiago between the poles of
existence so to speak and incidentally
enclosing me along with her the area
about me near the pattern group right is
the sunny morning while that at the
other end took on the aspect of a
baleful twilight were they about to
reenact the big bang crunch i wondered
with me as an unwilling momentary
witness and so uh merlin addresses them
uh your honors i began feeling obliged
to try to talking out of them
them out of it and wishing i were luke
who just might be able to swing such a
feat because luke is a great salesman
this is a perfect time to employ an
impartial arbitrator and i just happen
to be uniquely qualified if you will but
reflect
the golden circle that i knew to be
ghost wheel suddenly dropped over
nadia's head lengthening itself downward
into a tube
ghost had fitted himself within the
orbits of mandar spheres and must
somehow have insulated himself against
whatever forces they were exerting the
signs of the pattern and the logarithms
began to advance then and i crawled to
keep ahead of the pattern
don't come any closer fellows ghost
wheel suddenly announced so now what we
see is the ghost wheel artificial
intelligence that
merlin created which has been playing a
big role throughout all of these things
and figuring itself out is now going to
assert itself on the scene as a
third force
don't come any closer fellows there's no
telling what i might do if you make me
more nervous than i already
am
and
the um that you know they're sort of
contending
over the jewel
uh the ifks right uh the the uh logo the
logarist says return the eye of chaos
the unicorn took it from the servant
when they serpent when they fought in
the beginning it was stolen return it
return it
the blue face i'd seen about the pattern
did not materialize but the voice i'd
heard at the time responded it was paid
for with blood and pain
title past
and then dwark and says yeah these are
the same things and and
merlin says to dwerk and what happens if
the servant gets its eye back the
universe will probably come to an end oh
one of my bid for the thing ghost said
impetuous construct the voice of the
pattern and toned rash artifact whale
the logos save me the compliments and
give me something i want i could tear it
from you the pattern responded i could
have you apart and away in an instant
state of the logos but neither of you
will do so
because such a focusing of your
attention and energies would leave
either of you vulnerable to the other
then the ghost says tell me why this
confrontation need take place at all
after all this time
the balance was tipped against me by
recent actions of this turn coat the
logarist replied a burst of firing
occurring over my head
just a minute i wasn't given much choice
in the matter but there was a choice
whale the logarist and you made it
indeed he did respond to the pattern but
it served only to redress the balance
you tipped in your own favor redress you
overcompensated now it's tipped in your
favor besides it was accidentally tipped
my way by the traitor's father it was
not my doing and so what we see here is
you know the two of them essentially
contesting with each other
making their claims asserting that they
are the one who ought to have you know
what what is uh
there for for the taking and uh we find
again um that that there's going to be
yet further
um
discussions between them and what what
is actually happening well we turn to
the last
novel prince of chaos and there's a lot
of stuff going on in here because
everything's being ultimately well not
everything but most things are being
ultimately
revealed right
and one of the things that is happening
is
at the the place of the new pattern the
one that corwin created
so
he's talking to
um
corwin and he says this is the place of
your pattern
isn't it fiona brought me here once
yes came the reply and its image the
thing i saw confronting the sign of the
logos back in the graveyard the same
thing that went into the let us into the
tunnel
yes
then it's sentient too like amber's and
the logrus true
and he says
as we climbed out corwin said to luke
pattern ghosts tend not to last long
so i understand luke replied do you know
any tricks for someone in this position
oh i know them all sir it takes one to
no one as they say oh dad i said you
mean
yes i do not know where the first
version of myself might be which is
telling him i'm a pattern ghost
not the actual
corwin
and he says you don't seem this is his
son talking to him merlin you don't seem
exactly like the ones i recov i've
encountered
i'm not he said and he glanced towards
the pattern i drew that thing and i'm
the only person to ever walked it
consequently i'm the only ghost it can
summon
also it seems to regard me with
something other than utilitarian
attention we can communicate in a way
and it seems to been willing to devote
the energy needed to keep me stable for
a long while now we have our own plans
and our relationship seems almost
symbiotic i gather that those of amber's
pattern and those of the logos are more
in the nature of ephemera right there
they're not as long lasting
and
there's there's also seemingly a
difference
with the
other
path the the the new pattern
it seems more
benign more attuned to human beings
um
there's another place where merlin finds
out that he's essentially the product on
the part of his his mother and you know
the courts of chaos to be a um
you know sort of chosen one he's part of
a breeding process the logarist is going
to lead him to greatness she says uh
because you know he's now in the line of
succession and she says that you're
going to reign in the courts of chaos
and you know he says well i'm not really
i lack the skill and aptitude and
training i also desire for that and she
says you're better qualified than you
think and your desires have nothing to
do with that now
here's where we get some more important
information about this this conflict
she says the pattern is about to try
redefining the middle regions of shadow
between the pattern and the logarithms
in its own image it's probably strong
enough to do so
and
then
she goes on and she says the logos will
have to resist this incursion since it
would probably lose in a direct
confrontation with its opposite it's
forced to employ agents strategically in
a strike against amber
and they go on a little bit further
and she says you combine two great
bloodlines technically your father was
king of amber briefly between the reign
of oberon and that of eric
and then you know he says is that why
you wish to bear corwin's child the
logrus she says assured me such a child
would be uniquely qualified to reign
here an ideal lord of chaos
fit to rule
right
so the
this this conflict is that you know
merlin himself is the product of an
attempt to
um
settle this conflict now a little bit
later on
as the pattern is talking to him and
this is close to the end
of
the thing
here we go
it tells
merlin
choosing between the logrus and myself
is not a mere matter of politics
selecting this person or that to do a
particular job
my adversary and i
represent two fundamental principles by
means of which the universe is organized
you may tag us with nouns and adjectives
from most languages and dozens of
disciplines but we represent basically
order and chaos
apollonian dionysiak if you like reason
and feeling if you prefer madness and
sanity light and dark signal and noise
and as much as this may seem to indicate
it neither of us seeks the other's
extinction
heat death or fireball classicism or
anarchy each of us proceeds along a
single track and with the out the other
it would lead to a dead end both of us
know this and the game we have played
since the beginning is a far more subtle
thing ultimately perhaps to be judged
only aesthetically
now i have gained a significant edge
over my ancient adversary for the first
time in ages i am in a position
now to produce a historian's dream
throughout shadow an age of high
civilization and culture such as shall
never be forgotten if the balance were
tipped the other way we would be
contemplating a period of upheaval at
least on par with that of an ice age
when i spoke of you as game pieces it
was not to minimize your role in this
this is a time of great fluidity when
the jewel and the man who would be king
will make a difference stay with me
and i will guarantee the golden age of
which i spoke and you are pardon it
leave and you will be snatched away by
the other darkness and disorder will
follow
which will you have
and um
[Music]
we have luke there and luke says i know
a good sales pitch when i hear it
narrow it down to a simple choice make
them think it's their own coral squeezes
his shoulder we're going i said very
well said the sign tell me where you
want to go and i'll send all of you
there not all luke said just them i
don't understand what about you
now luke is going to
threaten the pattern he drew a dagger
and slashed his palm he advanced and
stood beside me extending his hand over
the pattern if we go only three of us
may arrive if that i'll stay here and
keep you company while you deliver my
friends right so this is a way to hold
power over the now ascendant pattern and
we see a similar thing
happening with
merlin a bit later on as well
and
what we're going to find out is that
we could call this another philosophical
theme
we've got chaos
we've got the pattern
you know the logos and the pattern
but we've got these third parties
and who is serving
you could call it the interests of
humankind who is
not willing to just treat things as you
know
chess pieces
in this eternal conflict that has been
going on forever and ever
well there's several different things
there's the new pattern created by
corwin
at the end of the fifth book
which is
trying to keep itself neutral but also
you know in some respects tilting things
over to the side of the other more
primal pattern
there are the
humans or people of amber themselves
who many of whom have now come together
they've put aside their differences as
they've figured things out there's also
the power of the
what's called the spikenard right this
ring
and um
[Music]
corwin's ghost tells him tells merlin
something about it he says
[Music]
they were said to be very early power
objects from the days when the universe
was still a murky place and the shadow
realms less clearly defined
when the time came their wielders slept
or dissolved or whatever such figures do
and the spike spike guards were
withdrawn or stashed or transformed
there are many versions but you know
bringing two of them to the courts could
be a big problem they draw all this
power from shadow itself so that's a
third option
and then we have
the ghost wheel
and the ghost wheel is
in a certain sense
the sun
the artificial intelligence sun
created
in shadow
so that it could actually
work to
look through all the shadows all at once
by
merlin as a
you know information device
but it becomes a new player in the game
so now we've actually got
multiple
things going on between these two
polarities that are essentially
interested in using everybody else to
fight against each other
and what we see is corwin or not corwin
well corwin is part of it he once he's
found but merlin
is able to
bring together
a whole bunch
of other forces to
create a new balance
to get them to
set aside
this now
zelazny says something very interesting
in 1985 so very early on
about ghost wheel
the ghost wheel is not a completely
physical machine merle built into it and
that's another reason why i gave merle
the ability to draw his own trumps so
that it could look through shadow i
wanted to place ghost wheel in a realm
where magic was more accessible that so
that some things i might do later which
could not be explained by the physical
function of a machine here would be
allowable there the ghost wheel is a
sort of sentient being itself
and so
to take back up this uh other
alternative uh theme so we've talked
about the massive metaphysical battle
that's going on and the great reveals of
the mystery it turns out that the the
mysteries other than the interpersonal
stuff about vendettas and hatreds and
stuff like that and who's got the keep
of the four
four worlds
it's all about the pattern and the
logarithms and
what escapes its grasp what sticks up
for
something else than what they
represent the pattern
doesn't really care about human beings
as such but
corwin's pattern
does
because that's what he
he built into it that's
the part of his personality he imparted
ghost wheel is sort of like
the pattern
in a certain sense it's an artifact
created by merlin just as corwin created
the new pattern
within
shadow to give
shadow a
greater opportunity same thing with the
spyguard ring that he uses and the same
thing we can say with these
key characters
uh corwin and and merlin
and uh luke slash ronaldo who is an
enemy at first and becomes a friend
um jert
uh joshua all of these characters coral
uh the the demon in uh nadia all of
these are trying to work together to to
save
life to put off this
seemingly metaphysical
final conflict
in favor of something
more
humane something you could say smaller
less metaphysical but equally valuable
and that's something that i see
as a key theme being developed and
worked out in these books as the mystery
unfolds as all the great magic is
discussed as we have each of these
interesting reveals there's a kind of
humanism
in the face of metaphysical
forces that are beyond our you know
capacity incredibly powerful
humanism
that is being
not just asserted
but
represented embodied
in what's going on and interestingly an
artificial intelligence
is able to play a role in that as well
and so we come to
a you know resolution at the
very end
of the um as it's called the triumphant
conclusion of the amber novels
at the the very end right
and so you know that that is where the
story is going to leave off and as we do
find out there are a lot of loose
threads left still open
going on in here
but um
you know a lot has been discussed a lot
has been resolved and it's great because
there's so much that one could still
imaginatively
play with in this and that's that's
where we'll leave off
you